so anyway I can read it to you it's
searching for probable word five hits
and it found five places then I tried
probable word space which on space said
no hits searching for power that one hit
then I said put in the word that because
they're all right that and that caused a
less than sign a nine and a minus sign
to come in a hyphen conceivable but the
less than sign isn't very good so then
it says backtracking to level zero ok
then I looked for the again and started
to insert the and I and I inserted as
many thousands I could and I started
getting I started getting garbage ok so
that's that was the initial thing and I
wasn't getting too far but a few minutes
later let's see
let's see what had finally happened a
few minutes later I got I got to the
following and see if we can look at that
and see what so it doesn't look like
anything very promising yet okay let's
take a look at the at the end thing here
where I tried for a period and a capital
th e I thinking that uh might occur at
the beginning of a sentence I also
trying to put myself in the mind of the
Bronte style if I could remember it but
I wasn't doing too well but I got a
period in a capital th e but the
previous letter was a capital W not too
good and I got an asterisk in this
message to however um there were there
were some other things that I better pop
tops it sort of just at random and one
of them was king ki ng period see the
cake the k's up here at the end of the
line there and ing there at the end and
I'm thinking oh wait a minute now this
might be talking about royalty someone
you know for that anyway I came with a
with a period at the end and then it all
no unfortunately it's been weakened or
something it could be making or thinking
right and and it has an o of something
ki ng period yeah I have a carriage
return line feed sitting in there and
then it says that this period of the
design to you and then then there was an
end and an RTC looking up there and lk
anyway I decided at this point to start
all over and and i liked the capital th
e business and
and I I thought I was trying a few
hypotheses here see what but this one
but this one gives us know so I've put
in walk I thought it going to have an lk
in it it might be walk and they got no
hits so I so I tried it without spaces
and I still got no hits so I decided to
give that that up then then on this some
you can see we are going to get King
carriage return hmm look for ck I didn't
seem to do any good oh yeah my still not
I'm still not getting anywhere on this
one I tried kingly I got no hits I got
King and got one hit I tried no King and
got no hits and I tried so and that's it
seems it seen you lead me into a dead
end actually okay um now but where was
the where was the moment that somehow
something seemed to work oh okay i think
it starts to happen here so let's take
this and some now I okay it started to I
ok I found a place where it looked like
it was comma space and and and that
occurs right in here comma space end and
then it looked like i have another space
in there with a six letter word with an
a so let me let me put that in big
letters comma and space and it was
unknown a unknown hg unknown space
and then these are unknown here so okay
so these are the two be filled in but I
have a space at the end there and a
comma and all of a sudden something what
do you think Mary I was thinking but
gathered but rather she said about over
and what father the letter before the H
is certainly a team anyway yeah so we
look at this looks like a tea we have
gathered rather father okay los finales
oh the way the last the last time notes
for me i'll probably are okay okay right
there could be an ass is resting would
see this before the age like that bad oh
yeah right okay writers however
combining with the with the comma in the
end I was thinking that probably it
would say and rather something or other
and see that that's no smut a fine I'm
giving more description about the other
and so I tried rather and I got I got a
hit there and so let's see in fact I
thought in fact I got two hits on rather
and it and the nice thing is that here
here was I got to to hit son rather and
the the first one also showed me a
semi-colon right before it so it turned
up a semicolon for all you know and then
rather in in the first line again that
was pretty good confirmation of the of
your typical you can imagine the Bronte
writing this book you know saying rather
something or rather you know because the
this kind of a punctuation she's
describing something this is literature
after all
so and so then now let's continue on
here it was something like this and
rather the next word was unknown o our
four unknowns and I guess I had a
carriage return line feed at that point
right here okay so rather something or
something okay well i mean i was getting
I was getting some idea that we we got a
descriptive passage going on in here
okay now so we had that so so let's go
back to Kathy and see if you can put
rather into your into your room is that
way for me to do that mommy I don't have
to silly way you can just guess word and
ask the program's trying my level
awesome places to put in you know things
going to go around foods Ned okay okay
okay so I haven't I would have to list
rather and then tell you where to put it
that's right yeah sorry
you have to say that a precise one space
too so yeah okay well yeah well why not
try to put rather in there anyway do you
have the stoop on you hmm I particularly
well account exactly where it is looks
like about oh yeah yeah I went in terms
of hits never see if they if they
messaged you know if I had a two-hit so
I would say put it in place of the first
hit or something like that but oh but
that's only still one one of many ways
to do it ah I mean let me explain well
but but ok I can count up and find the
first rather fix because I i can find
this ant this comma and rather also that
be easy because this is a 256 128 1 2 3
4 7 8 9 10 11 12 it looks like looks
like at 140 I've got it is what is tom
is here and rather yeah just to see if
that brings anything else in into your
thing that dog there was another okay
there was another thing ready to be
grouped but at the beginning that was a
let's drop price okay okay well try 130
941 yeah you got to retrack the other
stuff the bags better go back to the
program in okay I thought that's what
the bee did oh I stink oh ok yeah well
well I'm hmm I think you start over then
we can remember that we found people and
good and yeah all right how so okay now
on this one there was something that
that came up as I put in the word rather
on the first line I got a comma of and
then an unknown and then a wide in an
unknown and tea and then watch one not
yet right lest we forget whatever yeah
so it looked like it looked like a comic
con buyer yet would be another another
thing going in with the style of the
stuff that we already that we already
know okay so as you learn more about the
the author's style then of course then
the conjecture start coming faster but
that's right so absolutely yet started
to to intrude itself there and so I put
up or look for yet followed by a space
and I found two hits but not in the
place i thought i was going to get but i
but it turned out that it was yet
followed by a carriage return so this
was a space this would be at this was a
fair return line
arm and that was consistent and that was
by the way I do have a number here it's
139 Cathy it tells me in position
hundred thirty-nine so the comma was 839
instead of hundred forty sorry i'ma and
you rather young
oh good i got enough data to actually
give you some stuff not um so you want
to put the key fun rather rather in the
same thing how come you couldn't do it
all together so many between characters
in one day okay mama not didn't talk to
Lucy I'm human all right so rather goes
in 145 also in 25
ok now we got an 0 there as I mentioned
and the arch is coming somehow to maybe
25 sweetie all right this is a but this
is the 14 it's not a rather yeah I
talked i stood don't you ok so this is
right um I'm sorry you did just so I
could be awkward around in a guy the art
for the rider goes in young sitting in
25 rather high sitting against the San
Marcos in isolation 25 and also in 145
yeah and then I had yet um ok now let's
see what the same line alright so good
in it yeah let's try yet and I'm
carriage return line feed starting in
position 51
I'm not into the cages in my feet and
this time entering avoid playing this
character soul eater where the square
versus that the the carriage return line
feed yeah well yes was 51 so this would
be 15 yet was 51 and character 9 feet
was 54 you had space yep shoes i started
on 50 Robbie here ok
ok
okay so only seeing me better you know
semi phone rather coming yet and rather
and so I no no aji has popped up
everybody like they know oh yeah well it
takes take what we got so I'm hoping
that this this practice that this does
indicate some of the things that that
you'll be working on as you develop your
I speed programs for next Monday's
competition which is another character
turn in there and the barn floor yeah
you see exercise of the live feed right
right we can assume that it comes in
there we sat an IG Ziggy's back kazuma's
coming back again for us to check yeah
yeah we can ID blank blank blank comma
right right Oh blank blank ye comin
ignore hey no not at all knowing exactly
bigger worry instead it's an attraction
you arrived just in case ok ok all this
general doesn't work very well general
but I was using hmm it gives you
underscores for the collision oh yeah
jump the others as they are
station yeah I you're going through sale
that's one of the commissary yeah okay
so so now the rest of the so you know
here we we we have enough from coming in
now to look as though we're getting
we're getting somewhere toward the
message and we're getting something into
the star and it seems that that we're
going to have two kinds of issues one is
to get to get get get an initial wedge
and then after that is going to be then
game type of a problem be sure that you
think of both both our faces for the
final thing we looked primarily at the
initial exploration and so something
like being able to to put in a a word
anywhere or something like that or to
find out where all words go to look for
some kind of probability maybe
connecting with the frequency of text
exclusion needs might all be points that
would help for the for the final arm now
remember on Thursday is our special
guest lecture by professor come from our
department were quite fortunate to have
this and and also well he's excited
about giving giving it and so be sure to
not to miss this one coming up on
Thursday after which of course monday is
the big is the big competition okay see
you all